hey real quick so in this video we're
going to discuss a religious entity a
religious system that a lot of people
follow and are a part of we are in no
means attacking the people that are part
of it there are many really beautiful
genuine people who adhere to this
religion but we are talking about the
system and those who are heading it okay
so let's dive in in the colony of
Virginia we can see right here that
anybody who now they define the Sabbath
day here is Sunday but anybody who
didn't preach upon the or go to service
on the Sabbath day if you didn't do that
a couple of times I mean you could
ultimately be whipped but for the third
time to suffer death I mean there was a
death penalty in America early on if you
didn't rest on Sunday and you know that
Maryland had a Toleration Act I say the
Intolerable Maryland Toleration Act CU
it was anything but tolerable but the
Lord's Day called Sunday you had to rest
on that day cuz if you didn't you were
going to get publicly whipped and shamed
yeah I mean how many people have died
just because I said I want to keep all
of God's Commandments and I'm willing to
be tortured for
it welcome everyone to another episode
of LED live we're grateful that you can
join us on another Friday and we hope
that you will be blessed by the
information that we're talking about
today if you love history I love history
history I think you'll find this
particularly fascinating last time we
were with James we talked a little bit
about this subject too further back in
history and now we're going to continue
on with a little bit more modern history
and this is talking about the history of
the Sabbath so I hope you will be
blessed by this information and James
thank you for coming James has a YouTube
channel called biblical hope so we
encourage you to check that out it'll be
in the description below but James where
are we starting in the the stream of
time today so last time we talked a
little bit about pre-reformation but
this time we're going to talk a little
bit from that period going forward and
so perhaps some people might be aware of
John hus of course preceding Luther and
died as a martyr and there were
followers of his that became known as
the lards and in
1402 we have an example here of John SEO
who expressly held then and there that
the Sabbath was to be observed According
to which was observed in the Old
Testament now he wasn't alone there were
other law Lords as well in some history
for example William foyer of glow sister
was another instance of lard saboaria
ISM so there were individuals at this
time who held to the biblical Sabbath
and you know we can see push back of
that for example in the Council of Basil
session 19 many of these individuals
were accused of being Jews for keeping
the Sabbath and you know one of the
things that Rome did to prosecute Jews
was to actually mandate first off you
had to wear a distinguishing mark on
your garment wow so the same as with
Adolf Hitler what he did later on yeah
cuz that's where he got his idea EXA
yeah Kum nimus absurdum was the papal
bull where Pope Paul IV I believe it was
um who actually mandated that you had to
wear a a Insignia on you but among other
things um there was a clation that on
Sundays and other solemn festivals they
should not dare to have their shops open
or work in public so you had this war
going on back and forth between those
who kept the biblical Old Testament
Sabbath and those who wanted to restrict
business on Sundays and to enforce a
different day of the week and we see
this kind of building this war building
to the time of the Reformation of course
around 1503 even before Luther there
were individuals in Russia who were
burned in wooden cages specifically for
7th Day Sabbath keeping you have kitsen
Dimitri kopo and even maximov who were
burned in Russia but it was the brother
of casian who was burned at no gorad and
also Ivan maximov and kurton and this is
a uh a Russian work that I found right
here in 1858 that documents some of that
history and uh you know they suffered as
a result but around the time of the
Reformation of course you got arasmus of
reram who recognized that there were in
Bohemia a new type of Jews they call
sabbatarians who observe the sabbath now
you know were they Jews why would he
call them a new type of Jews if they
kept the Sabbath I mean that doesn't
make sense unless you're using the the
name Jew to actually uh as a theological
slur for Christians who began keeping
the Sabbath because the Jews have been
keeping it you know all the way back
right to call a new type of Jews he's
using it as a slur for these people who
and and I find it interesting for
Bohemia too because you know Bohemia is
a region where uh originally Peter Waldo
was from so there's that connection
there to you know the well denes back in
that region uh in the history so so the
original Christians mhm mixture of Jews
and Gentiles kept the Sabbath right and
and you can anywhere in your Bible
there's no reference whatsoever that the
Sabbath was changed to Sunday right and
so we come down history and the you know
partially due to Roman emperor
Constantine who wanted to pull uh pagans
into his Newfound Christian faith he
said well um you know to pull them in
we'll allow them to worship on Sunday as
well as a Christian holiday because you
know it's the day of the Sun and they
were Pagan worshiping the sun Etc
eventually Sunday disapp Sabbath keeping
disappeared because again they were
connected to the Jews and there was a
lot of hatred for the Jews uh and so
suay became more popular for many
reasons and so there was a long time
when Sunday uh was seen as the seventh
day what I find interesting by the way
is that if you go to Catholic ansers.com
they clearly say themselves that they
keep the eth day which is weird because
there's no eth day it's kind of the
first day of the week but so in this
time period that we're at right now um
I'm guess from what you're sharing it is
that yes the Christians had many or not
maybe not many a minority of Christians
had rediscovered the biblical Sabbath
started keeping it and I'm guessing that
this is not very popular yet right that
they were like oh these are like the new
Jews new kind of Jews so where are we at
here is this like Sabbath thing pretty
new here still and they're being
persecuted for it so the way I look at
it in in what I've seen in history is
you know there were Christians who
actually fled Roman persecution Roman
tyranny and so what you're seeing is
there were groups that were high in the
mountains in the wilderness regions or
even in the East you know far regions of
the Earth away from Rome who had kept it
and you're seeing them kind of reappear
and reappear and you're seeing glimpses
of this throughout the history uh
because in many cases they were Stamped
Out they were killed they were martyred
and so but yet there were still groups
who survived who continued to pass on
the torch y and you know one example of
that uh speaking of the East for example
Marco Polo's observations when he went
to the Far East was that the Sabbath was
passed with a celebration not seen
anywhere in the world so you know the
nestorians for example who were known in
the East to be keeping the Sabbath as we
talked about with some of the stells and
everything last time they kept it and
there were Witnesses who who saw that
now by the time of the Reformation
though there were some interesting
admissions from even Luther's opponents
for example this is John E right here in
his Incan locorum he said that the
church had transferred the observance
from Saturday to Sunday by virtue of her
own power without scripture and the
Latin right there is nullum habis
scripturum we don't have scripture so
it's extra scriptural it's it's not a
Biblical change yeah if you were to look
kind of and read
history we we look at
Luther very much as a a hero of the
Protestant Reformation and he and he is
but in his discussions or debates with
Dr
eek if you were to you know kind of rate
who wins and who loses Luther actually
loses on this point you know he he like
loses the argument against e because
this is kind of like the whole buildup
Luther's like yeah we should be going by
scripture alone and it kind kind of
tosses back like well then why aren't
you keeping the Sabbath yeah exactly
interesting and you know his Luther's uh
um friend of course carlot actually did
pick up on that and wrote heavily about
the seventh day Sabbath and so much so
that Luther in his V himn said that if
carlot were to write further about the
Sabbath Sunday would have to give way
and the Sabbath that is to say Saturday
must be kept Holy One More sermon now
you know we're going to see evidence of
some of Luther's later works here in
just a moment but one thing I want to
point out is this had gotten so hot in
the debates you know look at Minkin for
example or the Augsburg confession where
there were individuals who were saying
hey you know the Sabbath changed into
changed into Sunday the Lord's Day
contrary to the
decalogue that this was an example of
the power and authority of the church
since it could dispense with one of the
10 Commandments in fact the very
Augsburg confession delivered to the
emperor later on by the Protestants
indicated that this topic there was
nothing more hyped or cited than the
changing of the Sabbath day so if you if
you're looking for the hottest topic of
the Reformation this is it right here
and you mention Luther let's take a look
and see what he said right
here Martin Luther's in his final work
in Prim Li in this was his work on
Genesis and it was originally started in
1544 and uh of course by the time that
he died um you can see throughout it his
statements earlier in his lifetime where
he was very much Pro you know first day
of the week Pro Sunday now he's looking
back at Genesis and saying some shocking
statements here for example this one God
will that the command concerning the
sanctifying of the Sabbath should remain
he will that on the seventh day both the
word should be preached and also those
other parts of the worship performed
which he himself instituted now one of
the things that he also said was that
Satan uh was most likely he said is much
more likely that Adam sinned on the
seventh day that is the Sabbath just as
on the Sabbath also Satan the most
bitterly annoys and torments the church
while the word of God is being
preached but he goes on to state
that regarding the change from Sabbath
the Sunday that that was something that
Satan would have wanted to attack
uh you know to to destroy uh God's
creation there kind of like Paul
Harvey's you know if I were the devil
you know this is what I would do yeah he
says though these indications concerning
the Sabbath are not obscure but evident
and plain Satan therefore unable to
endure this most beautiful creation of
man and this holy appointment of the
Sabbath and envying him so much Felicity
and moreover seeing all things so
abundantly provided for him on Earth and
finding him in the possession of the
hope of everything after so happy a
Corporal life and eternal life which he
himself lost Satan seeing all this about
the 12th hour perhaps after God's sermon
to Adam and Eve himself preaches to Eve
so he's he's recognizing Satan's hatred
for the Sabbath right there yeah yeah
because you know so so what he's saying
is he's trying to create uh destroy
God's creation right as humans yeah yeah
so like why is that it's because the
Sabbath is literally God's symbol of the
of the uh uh creation and if you
understand the prophecies when it comes
to mark of the beast and when it comes
to the beast power you understand that
all of this is also incorporated into
the salvation of mankind and so for
those at home we do have a podcast
episode out on the Little Light Studios
podcast you can find any podcasting apps
and it's called what is the mark of the
beast and the Beast Power of Revelation
you can find out there for yourself how
does Sabbath connection uh ties into
that you know there were many
individuals who suffered at the hands of
the Inquisition though who kept this
seventh day Sabbath for example this one
Constantino Pon DEA fente he wrote that
these Works God prohibited on the
Sabbath not because they are bad but
rather that man may find himself
unencumbered for the true and spiritual
sanctification of the holy day so when
God prohibited works on the Sabbath day
it was to give man an opportunity to
rest reflect to spend time with his
creator MH yep and this became such a
Hot Topic of debate that by the time the
Council of Trent came around Rome had to
do something to quell these the charge
of those who said that they were Sol of
scriptura and so the way she went about
that is the there was an Archbishop
Gaspar deloso Archbishop of
Regio and he came into the council and
his solution was this okay the evidence
that these Protestants are not truly
solos scriptor is that when they still
cling to Sunday they recognize the
authority of the church there so they're
nothing more than Rebels they're they're
not claiming any kind of spiritual
superiority and he States here that the
Sabbath the most glorious day in the law
has been changed into the Lord's Day
these and other similar matters have not
ceased by virtue of Christ teaching for
he says he came uh he has come to
fulfill the law not to destroy it but
they have been changed by the authority
of the church and so by that statement
right there he was able to take all of
the fire out of the Protestants who had
only halfway
reformed and you know it's very sad as a
result they the Protestants could have
could have had a much more I think
powerful influence there had they
reformed all the way isn't there a quote
uh by the Vatican that says the reason
why we keep sun is because we do it to
honor the Church of Rome they they have
something like that yeah so I've got
some quotes like like that along those
lines uh coming up here but you're
probably going to find some of those a
little bit more recent and um yeah we'll
take a look at that within the last five
years I read a book on
hermeneutics and one of the important
points that came out of that is the
whole Protestant Reformation was
basically fought on the idea of
hermeneutics that being you know how do
you interpret and and translate
scripture how do you how do you read it
and you know that the Catholic Church
teaches that are the Expositor they are
the teacher they're The Interpreter of
scripture and that they're essentially
the only ones nobody else can interpret
it
so you know it's it's it's either one or
the other it's either they are or they
are not and if the Bible is true they're
not and then that makes other things
also true but if if it it's true that
they're they're the Expositor of
scripture then what they're doing is
defending their right to to these claims
that's all they're doing is they're
saying we we can interpret it for you
we're saying this is what it says and
you can't say otherwise but if you
remove that pillar they don't have as
many legs to stand on it's a two-legged
stool instead of three yeah you know um
the word of God has the ability the
capability to to promote truth in all
ages and I find it interesting in the
year 1566 that there were Witnesses who
saw that a belief was spreading Among
The Peasants that they must refrain from
working in the fields on
Saturday and this one particularly uh
there was a priest who was trying to
respond this particular priest Claude
Hatton was born around 1534 and he died
in
1605 but he was asking elderly people if
it was true that Saturday rest was
previously observed and that they
witnessed this young girl having
received uh miraculous uh Visions Etc
they had her arrested and questioned and
she was burned alive as a wenan and a
witch but we find actually several
instances in history where individuals
received visions and received
communication that hey you know the
right day of the week to rest was
actually the seventh day and so I'll
show more examples of that here in a
moment but it goes to demonstrate how
there were people who kept it but I find
the the charge of being a well denian
interesting cuz it goes back to the
previous uh discussions we had about
them in the 17th century we find
theophilos brbor who wrote about the
moral law consisting of the Ten
Commandments and the ceremonial law and
in Colossians 2:16-17 which a lot of
people today use to to say well the
Sabbath doesn't remain anymore he stated
wait there's Sabbath ceremonial and
there are sabbaths moral M and there's a
difference between the two and
Colossians 2:16-17 is going back to
Leviticus 23 which talked about all of
the feast and food and drink yep okay
which The Ten Commandments doesn't
mention but Leviticus 23 does in the
context of ceremonial sabbaths yeah so
so what you're making what you're
referencing to is Sabbath ceremonial is
those were the laws of Moses well God
gave them through Moses but they were
separate from um Sabbath moral meaning
the ten command
the weekly Sabbath so can you explain to
the viewers what are what is the Sabbath
ceremonial what are those multiple
sabbaths reference to yeah so we got to
remember that the biblical 7th Day moral
Sabbath was instituted at creation
before sin ever existed and the Sabbath
ceremonial were instituted after sin
came into the world as a result um you
know we have the sacrificial system the
feast days you know you think of like
Passover you think of um you know the
Feast of of trumpets or the Feast of you
know the day of atonement and all these
different feasts were implemented uh as
part of the sacrificial system to
cleanse people from sin and to lead
people back to Christ but what are we
going back to well we're going back to
the moral law and its
Perfection before sin ever existed in
the world and th the Sabbath at creation
remains for all time but these
ceremonial sabbaths will not always
remain because the goal is for mankind
to become you know back back in original
Purity one with Christ and that moral
law yeah so the ceremonial laws were the
ones that were crucified with Jesus on
the cross right he at that time was the
Lamb of God that fulfilled all of the
ceremonial laws which is why the the
curtain was torn apart in the sanctuary
in in unfortunately law of the Jews were
not recognizing what that meant it just
kept going with their ceremonial laws
and and and and all of these sacrifices
animal sacrifices that wasn't necessary
anymore but that was nailed to the cross
not the Ten Commandments it says in the
Bible the Ten Commandments are
Everlasting right one jot or one turt
shall not pass away until all be
fulfilled MH so the Ten Commandments
don't change they're for eternity yeah
yeah and and you know um one of the
other texts that's often mentioned is
acts 20:7 and Francis bamfield who was a
minister of Sherburn and dorsetshire he
was actually descendant of Sir Francis
Drake
stated that this night part belonging to
the afterday part as making up the whole
next day after the Sabbath was not
observed by Paul as the weekly Sabbath
so acts 20:7 yeah they got together they
broke bread but the very next day he
catches a ship to Asos and he didn't
rest at all on Sunday morning then so
you know there was a lot of discussion a
lot of study and a lot of individuals
that began to recognize this was you
know very prominent um this Dutch German
anabaptist for example ludvig vam Ernst
or ranhoff said that you must keep
Saturday is the day of the Lord because
God has ordained that day as such and
not Sunday that men have made for
that now of course many of these
individuals suffered martyrdom Barbara
volunteers when she was brought up for
charges they said regarding lady she had
nothing to say relative Sunday and holy
day she said that God had commanded to
rest the seventh day in this she aquest
it was her desire by the help and grace
of God to remain and die as she was for
it was the true faith and the right way
in
Christ
amen you know in the 17th century there
was a priest who responded to a sabot in
imaro our author seems to want us to
observe Sabbath was Sunday so there were
individuals who recognized that the
Sabbath needed to be kept and some of
the Catholic priests who responded for
example this bishop of Mew right here
they're like wait do you want us to keep
this in addition to the Sabbath so we
can see you know lots of these
individuals beginning to arise this is
one of the more interesting ones that
I've discovered here recently the
doctrine of the fourth Commandment
deformed by popery uh this was written
by James oord and it was written in 1650
all copies of it were ordered to be
burned by Parliament as erroneous
scandalous and profane now they burned
all of them uh that we know of except
for one that remains in Christ Church in
England so a couple of years ago or or
about a year and a half two years ago I
reached out and I said hey could you
guys photograph that they said well let
me get in touch with the conservator so
they did and uh we got photographs of it
and I had a chance to print it again
right here and this is the first
printing of the last remaining copy in
the world and so the work lives on even
despite the fact and actually it's been
made into an audio book as well now but
uh the work lives on despite the fact
that it was persecuted almost into
Oblivion where can people get the copy
or the audio book so the Audi book I've
got I've uploaded to my YouTube channel
and the printing I've only got a few of
these so I've got a couple there's a few
floating around the local area I haven't
found a way to mass print them just yet
but uh it's a wonderful work and you
know it demonstrates that there was a
lot going on here that has been
suppressed the truth has been suppressed
history is often written by the winners
yeah and so often times you know you and
I were discussing before the show
sometimes the only way you know about
something is because those who
essentially won or or had the other
upper hand talked about their enemies
you know yeah yeah they may have burned
everything they they wrote but they'll
complain about them and the things that
they believed and so on and so forth and
then you know like oh yeah there was
somebody who didn't have the same views
as you yeah mhm you know in 1615 there
was a Wy Pastor who got into a a tussle
with some uh some of the monks and they
accused him of being a Jew because he
observed no other holy days than the
weekly Sabbath so one of the things I
want to point out by this is this
exposes the lie that the wden sees when
they kept the Sabbath that meant Sunday
because what sense does that make to
call him a Jew if they're keeping the
Sabbath on Sunday you true right yeah so
in this was actually occurring in many
countries in the in this particular
Himel in the 17th century about half of
it this Bosnian sabbatarian Himel
referred to the Sabbath these people
were passionate about keeping the 7th
Day Sabbath so much so that nearly half
their Himel was about it and uh uh we
can see right here Samuel purchas in the
17th century again witnessing the
Ethiopians the Syrian who remembered
this he said they keep Saturday holy nor
esteem the Saturday fast lawful but on
Easter even they have solemn service on
Saturdays like the
Jews so there's you know lots of
evidence here Edward brewood in
1631 again commenting on the early
church that the ancient Sabbath did
remain and was observed together with
the celebration of the Lord's Day by the
Christians of the East Church above 300
years after our savior's death so I mean
that's a long time I found it
interesting that they call it the Sunday
the Lord's day cuz that's true that's
what the Catholics and a lot of other
Pro Protestant denominations
call Sunday the Lord's day but you know
in in the Bible it says Jesus says I am
the lord of the Sabbath that's exactly a
point that Peter Helen commented on here
he said that regarding athanasius you
know he told us that they came together
on the Sabbath day to worship Jesus
Christ the lord of the Sabbath mhm yep
yeah it's biblical man exactly in the 17
Century the Dutch there were Dutch
commandment Keepers here it is absurd to
maintain that Jehovah and the Old
Testament were right remember the
seventh day because I rested on it and
in the New Testament would say you shall
rest on the first day because I rested
on the seventh day like that's so that's
true it's a good point yeah interesting
logic yeah well you know you think about
it Hebrews 4:10 to rest as God rested
well I ask folks you know is first day
of the week is that resting as God
rested MH like no it's not the same well
what they'll say is that Jesus rose on a
Sunday so there but but in his grave he
even rested on the Sabbath day those who
came to um take care of his body it was
a Friday evening they wanted to honor
the Sabbath day that was right after he
died they still kept it yeah you know um
in the 17th century this is where it
starts to get a little interesting there
were individuals who recognized that the
mark of the beast corresponded to the
changes in the triple Hound crown Horn's
change of times and laws so this was
Peter Chamberlain who wrote a letter to
Archbishop Sheldon October 2nd 1673 and
I had a chance here to actually reach
out and get this from Oxford so this is
one of the first scans uh one of the
first instances among the first that
we're having a chance to actually show
this letter but he was writing and he
was a follower and student of this
fellow Thomas tillum whose works is this
actually work I've just recently put to
audio book as as well and another
Minister from that time period who began
to identify Sunday with Mark the Beast
I'll show those quotes here in just a
moment can they get this Audi book on
your YouTube channel as well yes yes
this one's available and actually you
can get prints of this book here from
Wilderness Publications uh this one
actually shipped to me from the UK so
yeah it's an awesome work right there
very powerful and it shows the kind of
thought process that was going on at
that time
there were several others for example
John trasy he was a traveling preacher
who held to extreme Sunday sabot Terian
ISM initially and one of uh one of his
disciples through the study of scripture
became concerned that they were
observing the wrong day and so this
disciple Jackson was struck by a
blinding light that he felt confirmed
his views and he convinced trasy and his
followers to begin to keep the seventh
day Sabbath trasy was ultimately later
on
arrested and ultimately uh he recanted
but his wife proved more enduring than
he was and she kept it and during her
last 25 years in prison she never
wavered from her belief and um it said
later on that she ultimately refused uh
well initially refused levitical
prohibited Foods later on in life she
moved to a better prison where she had a
little bit of a change in diet and uh
it looks like if I'm I'm reading after
this it says that the Jewish sabbath
ought to be observed and not ours and
that we ought to we ought to abstain
from all manner of swine's Flesh yeah
yeah so they were looking at some of the
other things yeah they were also looking
at yeah mhm fascinating yeah and this
this right here so this this is the scan
of Thomas tm's work actually got these
scans from Princeton um and this work
was written in
1657 but you can see this shocking
statement on the front cover of it with
the Christian glorious Conquest over
that Mark of the Beast and recovery of
the Longs slighted seventh day to its
ancient glory and he says right here the
changer of times and laws what charge
that upon Christ which is the proper
presumption of antichrist is not this
the wh's mark to change the Saints times
I mean that's pretty explicit right
there yeah yeah it's it's pretty bold
exactly yeah yeah and by the way again
for the audience at home we put out a
video about who the Antichrist is and
exactly verse by verse by verse so go
check that out yeah there's a lot more
on that cover here we could uh we could
comment on but you know there was
another sabatan actually Christopher
pulley who United with Thomas tillum in
this belief and he actually wrote the
preface to this other work by Thomas
tillum right here where he said that the
gospel owns no other times than the San
Sabbath in honor of the most glorious
work of
creation and uh there's another example
right here Edward stennet he said that
if the Ten Commandments be enforc every
jot and till of them it must necessarily
follow that the seventh day is the
Sabbath and it is to be observed
according to the Commandment but because
there is much opposition against this
truth I shall offer something in
particular to it which may tend to the
clearing of it now my point in bringing
this up is As we come to the 17th and
18th centuries sabari ISM especially
after the disastrous problems that
happened at Trent became huge there were
a lot of writers on the 7 sou
particularly in England so we're going
to take a look at that but also you know
it's interesting to look here around the
same time period the sort of tyranny
that we start to see in the United
States over the matter as well for
example in the colony of Virginia we can
see right here that anybody who now they
define the Sabbath day here is Sunday
but anybody who didn't preach upon the
or go to service on the Sabbath day if
you didn't do that a couple of times I
mean you could ultimately be whipped but
for the third time to suffer death I
mean there was a death penalty in
America early on if you didn't rest on
Sunday and you know that Maryland had a
Toleration Act I say the Intolerable
Maryland Toleration Act cuz it was
anything but tolerable but the Lord's
Day called Sunday you had to rest on
that day cuz if you didn't you were
going to get publicly whipped and shamed
so this topic this debate came to
America and there's even discussion as
we've talked about before with project
2025 that this is going to come back and
be the Hot Topic of debate once again
mhm next year right and you know we
talked about that vision of that girl
back in 1566 here's another one a boy in
Ager vexo dicese in
1667 an angel exhorted him to be
converted to forsake Pride the most
widespread sin and who taught him that
Saturday should be kept holy that it is
a sin to work on that day so even though
Rome suppressed the Bible God still had
ways of of pointing people back to the
truth right um have you guys heard of
monil loock before no that sounds
familiar yes yeah he was another one who
saw these kinds of visions and he was in
Alaska and it was known for when he
would travel Up and Down the kobuk River
of stopping on the seventh day and he
actually was known to prophesy as well
said a lot of things about Alaska that
later on did come true about you know
airplanes and motorboats and and uh he
talked also about Christ coming in the
Clouds Of Heaven and one of the things
that he said that it would be more
glorious than even the great lighted
displays of the Aurora Borealis or
Northern Lights oh cool you guys know we
had those recently they looked gorgeous
my media feed was flooded with them but
he said it's going to be more glorious
than that that's amazing and you know
down in uh in South America keeping on
this theme Here of visions that people
got there was an Indian chief AA who
asked the big spirit for help and an
answer he began receiving visions and
one of the things that he heard was
abstaining from eating unclean Meats
there's that swine flesh reference again
the seventh day Sabbath and prayer and
they even taught him a multi- part
harmony hymn shall We Gather at the
river interesting it's pretty cool so
there were a lot of individuals who were
jailed as a result um Joseph Davis was
one right here who talked about the sth
day Sabbath and he said here it is my
lot to sit here alone in the observation
of God's holy Sabbath yet not without
some precious tokens of his presence
which makes a Wilderness like an Eden a
desert like a garden of the Lord yeah I
mean how many people have died just
because I said I want to keep all of
God's Commandments and I'm willing to be
tortured for it you know in 1690 there
was a work here called The Widow's might
um humbly offered not imposed showing by
scripture why the seventh day of the
Lord's rest is to be kept in Christ
under the the name Christian and gospel
dispens
ations so you know there were many
individuals we got Thomas moer here who
talked about how the Primitive
Christians had a great veneration of the
Sabbath and spent the day in devotion
and
sermons but there was a warning here
about the little horn this was truth
defended or observations on Mr Ward's
expository discourses by George Carlo
and he States here
that some parts began to be infected
with Origins allegorical Divinity taken
from Taken Liberty to profane the
seventh day under pretense of keeping a
mystical Sabbath by ceasing from sin
while they lived in manifest sin of
citing the Sabbath so that the mystery
of iniquity got ground by this mystical
notion making way for the for the rising
of the presumptuous little horn to
change times and laws till at last he
prevailed with the emperor by decree to
establish the first day of the week now
which you guys know what little horn
he's talking about here mhm it's the
Antichrist power yeah well you know
Daniel had this Vision in chapter 7
verse 25 and this little horn thinks to
change times and laws you know but God
said you know I change not yep and so
there's only one power that tries to
change this was a work right here where
again you see this connection in the
18th century this was the mystery of
Lawless or Lawless Antichrist published
by Conrad betel where he
States thus and more danger it is with
the nominal Christians by sticking so
fast to that false Liberty sucked in by
the breasts of the and that's so
much worse because all of this pretended
under the name of Christ it's a bit bold
statement but he very much uh connected
that to the Harlot these kinds of
sentiments though came even from
Benjamin Franklin's Printing Press where
this work by Michael
welfare stated that the first day of the
week instituted without God and
scripture by the pope of Rome is that
same image whom all people tongues and
Nations and all Christendom so-called do
worship he connects it back to the story
in Daniel where you have the Hebrews
standing before you know the the image
and they're all commanded to Bow Down
and Worship it right mhm and he's saying
you know the entire Christian world is
basically bowing down to this image mhm
and there's only a minority who are
standing up for truth yep I think that's
an interesting statement that you're
making because I've been uh frequently
told well how can you think that the the
majority of Christianity is wrong you
really think that it's like I mean it's
a Biblical thing that the minority
usually is the one who has a right you
know if you look at the scriptures you
look at um you know prophecy and
Revelation in the last days it's not the
majority that's going to follow Jesus
Faithfully it's always the minority it
was the minority of the the Israelites
um when when Moses went up to the
mountain it was the majority that
worshiped the calf it was the minority
that didn't it's it's um you know the
minority in this case that or or with
the early Christians the minority were
the ones that stood for God and the
majority was P persecuting the minority
so it's go it's on going on throughout
the Bible and throughout history and in
our future you know I think about it
like our God is a consuming fire and
when he comes back back if you really
want to be fireproof and
survive like the Hebrews did in Daniel's
day then you've got to be keeping the
Commandments of God and that can only
happen by by you know allowing Christ in
it was Daniel's friends so they were the
minority that did not worship King
Nebuchadnezzar statue yeah always the
minority uh this particular work right
here Edward Elwell he talked about
how the Mortal men who know and believe
the fourth Commandment dare call any
other day the Sabbath which God has
never called so is it not a manifest
affront to the creator of the universe
so this change that occurred it was an
affront it was not respecting God's law
and William Wiston in 1748 joined him
the gross ignorance of the modern ages
has almost obliterated the
sanctification of Saturday or the
Sabbath day nay is introduced without
all good authority such an
interpretation of the fourth command as
if the Lord's day was to be the
Christian Sabbath and you know in the
18th century we see another one Robert
corn WTH here it is by no means the duty
of Christians to comply with any such
abreg or change but also that the
observation of the ancient 7th Day
Sabbath is our most certain
[Music]
Duty now you guys might have seen some
claims to Revelation 110 you know uh do
you guys remember John's remark in the
spirit I you know I was in the spirit on
the Lord's Day right so they say well
that Sunday um I think there's plenty of
evidence to suggest that he was speaking
about Judgment Day at the end of time
which if if you look at it through Mark
22728 the Lord's day is the Sabbath mhm
but so did this fellow right here Henry
Dawson he stated Rejoice that you
entirely agree with me the seventh day
is the Sabbath and the seventh day
Sabbath is the Lord's
day now there were a lot of other indiv
uals as well Argentina had a sabotaging
hero from 1820 Francisco Ramos maxia
who was actually persecuted quite a bit
and he said that casting out from it the
memory of Sunday the the 7th and
restoring the delightful law of the
Sabbath that of the will of the
Creator and he advocated quite strongly
down in Argentina in the 19th century
for the 7th Day Sabbath now this was
another interesting remark right
here we have in 1826 by JB
shenston uh he was um ordained Elder of
the General Baptist Church in April 23rd
1799 and he said that my object is to
place this subject in a clear and
scriptural light to show that in regard
to the Sabbath which in all hands
allowed to be of such vast importance to
man there exists no such Apostolic
example that no civil or ecclesiastical
Authority however great can be finding
on the consciences of men like the
express command of God and that he has
instituted the seventh day with a view
to its Universal and Perpetual
observance by mankind you know the in
the 19th century there were individuals
who uh promoted the 7th Day Sabbath
James beg was one of them this was his
work here an examination of the
Authority for a change of the weekly
Sabbath the resurrection of Christ
proving that the practice of the church
in substituting the first day of the
week for the appointed 7eventh day is is
unsanctioned by the New Testament
scriptures uh so throughout history
there are have been those who keep the
Commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus MH now our Catholic friends
will likely respond and to them we we
would point out Cardinal James Gibbons
who actually said himself that the
scriptures enforce the religious
observance of Saturday a day which we
never sanctify he said you may read the
Bible from Genesis to Revelation you
will not find a single line authorizing
the sanctification of
Sunday Keith didn't you mention recently
how many times um the Sunday is
mentioned in the New Testament versus
how many times Sabbath is mentioned just
in the book of Acts
alone yeah in in all of the New
Testament there's only eight references
to Sunday and five of those are the same
event so if you were to take those five
and distill them because they're all
talking about the resurrection
two of them in John and then the other
three are in the other gospels that's
essentially like one one event right so
one event out of the out of those five
that means you only have three more so
it's like having
four scriptures to stand on yeah which
is not a lot and there's there's nine
references to the Sabbath in the book of
Acts alone yeah and if you think about
it right like um people say well uh
we're keeping the Sunday because well
the Lord Resurrected on that day I
personally feel like that's a very not
very strong argument for Sunday keeping
if it's just well this happened on this
day so therefore I'm going to do this
versus if you love me keep my
Commandments it's in the Ten
Commandments um you know one jot on one
H shall no so no wise pass away um until
all be fulfilled I mean there's so many
references to like oh um if um here's
the patience of the Saints here are they
that keep the Commandments of God which
was referring to people in the last days
who are faithful to Jesus when the mark
of the beast comes about um Sabbath is
being kept in heaven I mean the
comparison is just there's so much
weight on the Sabbath side and like
nothing on the Sunday keeping side yeah
in fact you know even the Baptists
admitted this uh this was Alexander
Campbell who said it is all old wives
fables to talk of the change of the
Sabbath from the 7th to the 1 day if it
be changed it was that August personage
changed it who changes times and laws EX
officio I think his name is Dr
Antichrist but uh you know ly Layman
Abbott the congregationalist admitted
that the current notion that Christ and
his Apostles authoritatively substituted
the first day of the week for the
7eventh is absolutely without any
Authority in the New
Testament so where did this all come
from well the faith of millions uh by
Jack O'Brien this was a Catholic book
right here that said but since Saturday
not Sunday is specified the Bible isn't
it curious that non-catholics who
profess to take their religion directly
from the Bible solo scriptura right mhm
who profess to take why do they observe
Sunday instead of Saturday well he says
yes of course it is inconsistent but
this change was made 15 centuries before
protestantism was
born probably referring back to like
Constantine and and some of the other
stuff that happened um he says though
that uh that observance remains as a
reminder of the mother Church from which
non-catholic sex broke away like a boy
running away from home but still
carrying in his pocket a picture of his
mother or a lock of her hair now I find
his reference to the mother Church
interesting don't we see a mother Church
in the Revelation
mhm and so you
know it's not something that Christ and
the apostles taught I find it
interesting that um you know a lot of
Protestants don't even understand what
Protestant means it means to protest
um this the Protestants came about
because people like Martin Luther and
zwingley and hust Jerome and all the
reformers spoke against the Pagan
mixture of Christianity that the Roman
emphasis of Roman Catholic Church was
putting about right and you know one of
those things was Sunday in in honor of
the venerable day of the sun like it was
Sun worship um I find it interesting
that that
the there's many
Protestant reformer ideas that have come
down Through the Ages through the
centuries but that people who say
they're Protestants which really means
you're protesting aren't in fact
protesting anymore against the system or
the mother church and that they have
really adopted an understand unknowingly
um a day that honors the son God which
was put into place by the whole system
the Vatican that they their forefathers
protested against in the first place
right so they're still the mother Church
Roman Catholic Church is they call
themselves The Mother church still has
its tentacles so to speak to hold these
people these Protestants
unknowingly in their hands so that's
where you know 19 1900 we have you know
statements like Sunday is a Catholic
institution its claims to be observant
can be defended only on Catholic
principles from beginning to end of
scripture there's not a single passage
that warrants the transfer of the weekly
public worship from the last day of the
week to the first and this is coming
from Catholic Press the leading Catholic
paper of Australia so this is themselves
saying it yeah and you know in 1923 the
Catholic record stated that we have the
authoritative voice of the church the
voice of Christ himself the church is
above the Bible and this transference of
Sabbath observance from Saturday to
Sunday as proof positive of that fact
it's pretty fascinating that they don't
try
to really
defend yeah you know the keeping of
Sunday any under under any scriptural
pretense or try to point to other texts
or anything like that you never find
that over and over and over and over
again in their documents they're just
like no we think that the church is
teaching which I forget what that's
called is it like the magisterium or
something like that we think the
church's teaching is is on par or ex or
exceed the authority of
scripture you know they they took that
though so far as to level this sort of
attack against Protestants this was a
work in 1895 a fifth edition copy of it
right here but it was published in the
Catholic mirror and one of things that
they did is look if you're Protestant
and you keep
Sunday you're standing on a claim that
they said was groundless
self-contradictory and suicidal
because the thing is is that if you keep
Sunday you logically must recognize
Roman Authority cuz there's not anounce
of scripture so what they did is they
actually went through in this work all
of the classic scriptural texts that are
used like acts 20:7 and others and
presented them to Protestants and say
look you're not you're standing on a
twig right here you're standing on
foolish fire ignis Fus in this instance
and went themselves and demonstrated how
look acts 20:7 if you go back to acts
2:46 they broke bread daily so 2 vers or
20:7 proves nothing for your position of
keeping Sunday unless you accept Roman
Authority so why not come home to the
mother church so was it the Roman
Catholic Church at that time that
started creating these doctrines that
that Protestants use nowadays to speak
against the Sabbath like this kind of
stuff Protestants had tried to use these
for many years uh this was a
continuation right here of the ideas
from the Council of Trent though that
there is no scripture that establishes a
CH
it's the authority of the church that
dictated it and Protestants had been
relying on their misunderstanding of
these scripture texts for a long time to
defend their position and Rome's like
wait you really don't have any kind of
scripture here to back up Sunday so if
you're going to keep Sunday you might as
well come home to the mother Church M
and there have been a lot over the years
that have with the exception of one and
in that same work they stated that there
was a group of people called Adventists
who were the only body of Christians
with the Bible as their teacher who can
find no warrant in its pages from the
change of the seventh to their first
their Cardinal principle consists in
setting apart Saturday for the exclusive
worship of God in Conformity with the
Positive command of God himself
repeatedly reiterated in the sacred
books of the Old and New Testament
literally obeyed by the children of
Israel for thousands of years to this
day and endorsed by the teaching and
practice of the Son of God wst on Earth
in other words they know that there is
one group over here that denies their
Authority and actually is solos scrip
Tor H and you know there's there's some
works there was a priest Conway Bertrand
Conway who wrote this regarding this one
group of Christians that if the Bible is
the only guide for the Christian than
the Seventh Adventist is right in
observing Saturday with the Jew aren't
don't Protestants claim to be solos
scriptura well in actuality according to
this admission right here there's only
one solos scrip toura uh
denomination this was a publication by
Leo Brodrick now Leo brri was was a
graduated from the Sacred Heart Seminary
in 1952 with Bachelor's in philosophy
and did his graduate Seminary work at St
John's provincial Seminary and received
a masters of
divinity he was a priest and in 1995
wrote this in the Sentinel that people
who think that the scripture should be
the sole Authority should logically
become 7th Day ven Keep Saturday
holy and you know this trend just kept
continuing in 1950 you've got the
Australian Catholic truth Society record
who said that 7thday Adventists are
right however in accusing other
Protestants of inconsistency who speak
of any obligation of Sunday observance
whilst rejecting the authority of the
Catholic
church so you know it's interesting to
me to find that when the dust settles
there's one solos scriptura church and
you know going back to Thomas tm's
claims right here do you guys remember
what what did he call Sunday the Lord's
day well he called Sunday uh the mark oh
right right right yeah yeah so you know
I find that that concept interesting
it's alluded to in quite a lot of
documents for example Das Domin we see
that the Sunday Assembly is the
privileged place of unity it is the
setting for the celebration of the
sacramentum untis which profoundly marks
the church as a people gathered by and
in the unity of the father and of the
son and of the holy
spirit in the catechism of perseverance
what is the Blessed bread it's
distributed at Sunday mass as a mark of
the Union that ought to exist among all
Christians or this one Sunday mass
observance became a mark of a practicing
Catholic there are some statements there
alluding to this Mark right
mhm why is that a
concern Revelation 13 M right you know
going back to Exodus 31 we see that God
has this seal that was to mark his
people in Ezekiel 20:20 and 20:2 we can
see that alluding to the sth day Sabbath
we can see in Exodus 139 Deuteronomy 6:
6-8 yep that God's law was to Mark
forehead and it was also to mark your
hand right but here we have a
counterfeit Mark yep that Revelation
describes will mark hand and forehead
what what's hand and forehead what is
that symbolic of I think the text that
you mentioned in Deuteronomy is the one
that really kind of describes it because
that's the first time you see it in the
Bible yeah so if we go there Deuteronomy
6 so when you're at verses 6 through 8
you mentioned yeah
um when
you when you're reading this it
says um you shall love the Lord your God
uh before this with all your heart with
all your soul and with all your strength
and these words which I command you
shall be in your heart well if you read
that you should be thinking
why right why does God want them there
why does he want those words there and
what words is he talking about he had
just given the Ten Commandments in
Deuteronomy chapter 5 and doesn't
Hebrews 8 talk about the Holy Spirit
writing on our heart yeah
so is it it is also from Jeremiah yeah
as well so if we're asking ourselves
well what words the question the answer
to that is the words that he just spoke
on the mountain Deuteronomy chapter 5
spoke them audibly this time they
weren't just written they were
Audible and then he says I want them to
be in your heart well why because a
heart here is is not just you know this
place of emotion it's it's the Mind God
wants them in their mind and and then it
says you shall teach them diligently to
your children you shall talk of them
when you sit in the house when you walk
by the way when you lie down when you
rise
up
why right why why teach them because
it's evident that when they're in the
mind and they're being taught those
things are going to come out in the life
they are going to be the actions yeah
so that's why he then says when you get
to verse 8 and says you shall bind them
as a sign on the hand
so that they'll do them and then you
know there should be a sign as frontlets
between your eyes because you're going
to be thinking about them it's because
you've taught them to be carried out
yeah yeah so I you know I think about it
like you know to be marked on the
forehead is symbolic of like what you're
thinking what you believe and then on
the hand is what you're doing there's
there might be some people at the end of
time who when they're faced with the
crisis of Revelation 13 they might think
and know something is truth but with
their hands they're going and doing it
or vice versa they might be um you know
going and
and uh maybe with their hands doing
something that looks outwardly
appropriate but their hearts not
converted right right and what I find
interesting too is that what kind of
part of the brain is behind the forehead
it's the frontal lob right it's
literally the seat of morality yeah of
worship of spirituality
like that's what you use that part of
the brain for it's the decision making
part of the brain I mean that's
fascinating I you know if we use a
literal
hermeneutic and we say well we're
looking for a mark on the hand or
forehead you know like a like a barcode
or something it reminds me of the Jews
who
interpreted the uh border of garments
you remember the the um the Flores and
whatnot for example actually these same
same verses right here when it talks
about bu in the law around your arms
they would take the law of God and they
would literally wrap it around their
arms written copy you know what sense
does it make to have the law of God
wrapped around your arm while you're
going out and killing somebody like
doesn't make any sense is that really
what God had intended or did he really
want you to actually abstain from
breaking the law of God so if we look at
it from this perspective it makes so
much more sense when you look at
Revelation 13 and the mark you know and
and and all of the warnings there
because it connects directly back to the
law of God and Rome here has a
counterfeit to that God has a
true uh Mark or sign and Rome has a
counterfeit to it and they've said so as
much so the question I ask folks is at
the end of time when this issue comes to
the Forefront of debate as it will as
we've seen with project 2025 do you
really want that profound mark from Rome
that's not something I want no no I want
the genuine yeah yeah mhm the Seal of
God which is the Sabbath exactly
speaking of um you know remembering the
resurrection there is a Biblical text
that does teach us how we are to
remember it in in we find that in 1
Corinthians it says for as often as you
eat this bread and drink this cup you
proclaim the Lord's death till he's
coming or till he comes so God
did give us a way to remember Christ's
resurrection that is biblical and it was
communion yeah but he
didn't ever
reference um keeping Sunday as a holy
day as a methodology for doing that yeah
so and I think it's really important in
this
discussion that here we are we're
bringing out a lot of things that are
that are probably very controversial in
the Protestant world and it's fine um I
think it's fine because we're not here
saying uh to be pushy right like do this
or else which is what we are saying has
happened in history for many years where
this issue has come up and usually you
know and those in the majority are like
you need to keep Sunday or else yeah
that's wrong right God never did that
and so we are we are just saying hey
take a look at the evidence take a look
at the Tex
decide for yourselves but we're never
going to come at you with you know you
better do this or else we are saying if
you study prophecy out to it in
conclusion you want to be on the right
side of Eternal history because we think
it's it's it's a point that matters that
God believes matters but God gives you
the opportunity to choose what you're
going to do and what you're not going to
do yeah and that's okay you can you can
you can you can choose either way
God is not ever going to force you yeah
um but he does say if you love me keep
my Commandments he does and and and
that's you know and that's our what
we're giving is an invitation right
that's all it is and we would never
advocate for force in either direction
like we don't think anybody should force
or push the Sabbath just like we don't
think anybody should force or push
Sunday yeah but we are saying the way
prophecy is
going that's what's going to happen and
that should be a clue you know that uh
this is not a good thing when you force
worship one day or another God wants us
to keep the Commandments however like
you're saying he doesn't push anybody to
keep it he wants free will free will
worship and Out of Love not force you
you really have to have that kind of
free will if you think about um going
back to Nebuchadnezzar and standing
before the image the one who used force
and coercion was Babylon mhm and the
ones who served out of love would rather
give their own lives for God and die in
a burning fiery furnace than break God's
law were the very ones that God turned
around and honored yeah and spared
because there was a loving relationship
there and in their Zeal you see time and
time again these Pagan Kings after God
delivered his people whether it was from
the fire or from the Lions or whatever
they then tried to make a decree that
was like well now everybody needs to
worship the true God they're kind of
missing the point right biblically but
you know what what what's fascinates me
is is that I think that in some level
they must have seen that the love that
God had for his people and that touched
their heart you know with Nebuchadnezzar
you know we see a change of heart there
where the fact that God came in and and
uh and saved his people you know that
really spoke to the character of a
loving God right there it did yeah and
and not to say he was fully educated at
that point he was making a split you
know momentary decision without having
you know all the cards laid out on the
table yeah so yeah I think that's that's
really a big point in all of this is
yeah we're saying some really heavy
stuff but it's not to say do this or
else because that's what's happened on
the other side of history and it's never
really worked out very well for anybody
except those in power and control yeah
so um you know what we're just saying
take a look at the evidence study
history study the Bible study prophecy
and let let let God's spirit work in
your life to bring you to the you know
to that conclusion do you have something
else you were going to talk about some
video pointed to more information so we
have recently uploaded I mentioned one
video before what is the Antichrist
power and the Beast Power and we
recently just uploaded a video uh what
is the mark of the beast we walk through
it verse by verse and I can tell you if
you watch this there's no out about who
the Beast is/ Antichrist and what the
mark of the beast is and also if you
want to have a a different take on that
again go to our podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts Apple Spotify um and
the episode is called what is the mark
of the beast and the Beast Power of
Revelation if you want to learn about
more where we're coming from biblically
we do have a Bible school it's at
ls. Bibles School says more of a a
holistic approach instead of just a on
topic approach where you can study out
where we're coming from so we encourage
you to take a look at that um I want to
thank James for joining us on another
history Adventure so thank you for
coming you want to take a look at what
James is doing you can go to biblical
hope it's a YouTube channel we'll put
the link in the description below also
if you want to help support the kind of
work that we're doing we encourage you
to uh go to our website make a donation
ll. you can also find us on patreon if
that's more convenient for you um also
we have shirts we have uh lightwear shop
so take a look at that you might see
something that you like a lot of
creative designs that'll help you in
your witnessing Journey so thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
on another episode of LED live until
next time take
[Music]
care there has been very few movies in
the history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money or is there something
more nefarious behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
created you
job and he for you isra
in the temple of my God and he shall go
out no more I will ride on him the name
of my
God
[Music]
strength shall
R PR alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
you
[Music]